three gamers in action Sawyer dozer and
wiesen from the crash academy youtube
channel have agreed to go offline to
visit the berlin museum of communication
they're checking out the no pain no game
exhibition for euromaxx here the world
of computer games comes alive taking on
a physical dimension take the pain
station for instance players use their
right hand to play pong but every time
they make a mistake they're left gets
punished electric shocks heat and slaps
whoever pulls their hand away first
loses it's a case of physical and
psychological warfare how the vivaz
pasta left while it's definitely fun you
get really competitive despite the pain
you can't pull away because you don't
want to see Michael wimp this is a new
experience for the gamers normally they
produce let's play videos to make them
they film themselves playing and provide
a running commentary throughout stop
your Diaz he pushed up into you yah yah
haha by Gooden for locking the videos
are a big hit online
that's all me you know millions of
people watch it it's kind of a mix of
sports and gaming you can take part
yourself and see how others are doing
the understand can't feel a little tease
will no longer play much themselves but
like watching other people gain it's a
form of entertainment come Natalie
movement of course it's important for us
to pack a lot of tips tricks and
know-how and news into our videos and to
bring people on board packing da noise
when the annoyance or to transport yet
even here at the exhibition the guys
find it hard not to provide a running
commentary even when playing alone in
the furminator round two Candice coulis
start game come from n stuff and some
amazing voices of the optics a hammer
this is just one of ten exhibits by
cologne based artist duo tillman rife
and folk amor Ava also known as fer all
of their ten installations feature an
interactive component players have to
exert themselves both physically and
mentally some of the games are even
voice powered
the bow and I book a games that we build
challenge users to interact with the
computer in a particular way Thunder not
advised the MIT dem computer through we
experiment with the different forms of
communication that exists between people
and machines machinae of voltage Leisha
art advisor ohmic Vic from bhm exactly
it's a move away from thumbs and screens
so false dawn it's about fists and
singing Fulghum araba and Tillman rife
have been working together since 2001
their first collaboration the pain
station was a huge hit the unusual games
console even made it into the museum of
modern art in new york but no pain no
game is their first solo exhibition it's
supported by the German cultural
institution the goethe-institut after
touring Eastern Europe it's now being
shown in Germany for the first time the
idea is to rekindle people's passion for
play
doesn't even it's something that somehow
gets lost kids are totally open i do
everything saying scream try new things
press every key they don't worry about
anything as you get older you lose that
this exhibition gives you the chance to
be a kid again but maybe move decayed
maybe their kids tonight round three it
doesn't take the gamers long to find
their inner child they dive right into
the snake pit a physical take on an
early cell phone game so at the problem
no this is not 1993 but I think we all
played this game on our old nokia 6310
yet the [ __ ] no I'm right across from
him we're even bumping into each other
eating nothing as onsen so what's the
verdict he fit this [ __ ] and I think
it's a great concept it really
challenges players physically it's so
much harder than just playing with a
joystick and hitting a few keys you know
what I'm talking about gaming brought to
a whole new level
no pain no game is all about
rediscovering the joys of playing a
physical challenge in a digital age
there's our guy